2 du mandat qui nous a été donnée par le
sénat et croyez-moi nous le faisons avec
beaucoup de respect pour la difficile
fonction que vous exercez à la tête des
femmes et des hommes qui font partie du
groupe de sécurité du président de la
république et nous mesurons bien la
difficulté pour vous de venir apporter
votre témoignage est sans doute aussi
vos réflexions à la commission des lois
du sénat alors que vous vous inscrivez
naturellement dans une hiérarchie que
vous avez aussi le devoir de respecter
je voudrais vous dire que je les dis
assez souvent au commencement de ses
auditions mais j'éprouve
particulièrement le besoin de le dire
quand il s'agit de l'audition d'un
serviteur de l'état qui remplit une
tâche particulièrement difficile et
importante pour la république
nos auditions sont destinés à nous
permettre de voir clair ce sont des
auditions et les mondes sans ce ne sont
pas des comparutions et donc elle ne
postule pas qu'il y aurait des choses à
reprocher aux gens qu'elle nous
auditionnons mais nous avons besoin
d'eux pour concourir à notre travail d'
enquête parlementaire que le sénat nous
a confié à l'unanimité lundi dernier et
c'est très important pour nous de vous
entendre et d'avoir une vision
professionnelle de ce qu'est
l'organisation de la protection du
président de la république tout en
sachant que vous n'avez pas nous des
volets de secret de fabrication et qui
peuvent être j'utilise cette expression
approximative pardon et qui peuvent être
nécessaires à la qualité de la
protection du président de la république
donc ne nous dit du point de vue
technique et pratique que ce qui vous
paraît possible de vous dire mais nous
avons des points à clarifier qui sont
plus délicats peut-être pour vous
notamment les relations entretenues
entre l'adjoint au chef de cabinet
chargé de mission à la présidence de la
république monsieur benalla et votre
groupe puisque lui-même dans plusieurs
déclarations n'a pas hésité à faire état
de relations tendues c'est sur la place
publique et peut-être n'avez-vous pas
perçu ces tensions mais lui en tout cas
les expriment nous auront naturellement
et je le regrette à vous poser des
questions précises sur sur ce point et
vous nous direz ce que vous rares et
pouvoir être nous dire comme même pour
toutes les personnalités que nous avons
auditionné je vais devoir vous rappeler
ça n'est pas une suspicion particulière
mais c'est la règle de notre procédure
car faux témoignage devant notre
commission des lois doté des
prérogatives d'une commission denquête
serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amande et je vais vous inviter à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levé la main droite
et dj lui jure je jure je vous remercie
mon colonel
comme c'est d'usagé je vous propose
d'introduire votre proposition par un
cours propos dans lequel vous pourriez
peut-être nous présenter votre service
et éventuellement commencer à lever le
voile sur les difficultés qui ont pu
apparaître dans la collaboration entre
l'adjoint au chef de cabinet monsieur
benalla et hop de sécurité du président
de la république vous avez la parole
est-ce qu'on appuie comme ça ce monsieur
président madame l'accord à porter
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
votre commission denquête mène sa
mission d'information
il est important de rappeler le cadre
sur les conditions dans lesquelles des
personnes n'appartenant pas aux forces
de sécurité intérieure ont pu ou peuvent
être associés à l'exercice de la mission
de maintien de l'ordre et de protection
de hautes personnalités ainsi que le
régime des sanctions applicables en tant
que maman poule
je m'efforcerai de répondre avec le plus
de clarté à vos questions et j'en
profite
dans ses propos liminaires pour vous
remercier de me donner la possibilité de
m'exprimer pour apporter un certain
nombre de précisions
dans ce cadre je veillerai à respecter
le principe de séparation des pouvoirs
qui me permettra ni de répondre aux
questions portant sur des faits en lien
avec l'information judiciaire en cours
ni à celle portant sur l'organisation
même interne de la présidence de la
république
enfin ma position spécifique au coeur du
dispositif de sécurité de la présidence
de la république m'oblige à respecter
une vigilance toute particulière en
matière de protection du secret de la
défense nationale
ainsi je ne pourrais pas abordés
les différents modes d'action
nécessaires à la protection du président
de la république
ceci étant dit je vais commencer à
répondre à une de vos questions en jeu
le président mesdames messieurs
concernant qu'est ce que ce qu'est le
j'espère ce quelle unité que je
dirigeais le j'espère est une entité du
sd élevé service de la protection de la
police nationale
ces missions sont clairement mentionné
dans l'article 4 de l'arrêté du 12 août
2013 relatif aux missions et à
l'organisation du service de la
protection de la police nationale ces
missions je cite sont sur le territoire
français et à l'étranger d'assurer la
protection personnelle et immédiate du
président de la république et de mettre
en oeuvre les mesures nécessaires à sa
sécurité notamment à l'organisation
matérielle et à la sécurité de ses
déplacements
les effectifs du j'espère en l'état
actuel sont de 76 personnel femmes et
hommes répartis comme suit 40
fonctionnaires de police et 36
militaires de la gendarmerie
je poursuis par rapport à vos questions
vous avez vous est posée monsieur le
président quelles étaient les relations
entre monsieur benalla et le j'espère on
va aller dans le vif du sujet alors
monsieur b dallas était à la chefferie
cabinet j'ai vu que vous avez appris ce
nom bizarre chez free cabinet mais c'est
le nom us vaud avec plaisir vos sujets
de travaux donc on ne met absolument
absolument tu veux je vais vous avez des
références assez lointaine géographique
donc monsieur benalla était à la
chefferie cabinet il officie dans toutes
ses missions sous l'autorité du chef de
cabinet monsieur françois xavier lorre
jeu alexandre benalla était chargé de
mission adjoint au chef de cabinet je
précise que dans la chefferie cabinet il
y a le chef de cabinet il ya le chef
adjoint de cabinet qui sont nommés au
journal officiel
et il ya deux chargés de mission adjoint
au chef de cabinet d'eau faisait partie
monsieur b d'alain ses missions je vais
je vais les séquences et de manière
temporelle ça va vous donner des
éclairages sur quels étaient ses
missions et ses relations avec le
j'espère jusqu'au 1er mai 2018 ces
missions étaient triples la plus
importante mission c'était la
participation à l'organisation des
déplacements officiels du président de
la république sous l'autorité du chef de
cabinet
à ce titre il assuré la coordination des
services qui concourt à l'organisation
du déplacement conformément au programme
qui sont arrêtés par le chef de cabinet
quand on parle de coordination des
services dans ces services là il y a le
j'espère mais il n'y a pas seulement le
j'espère il ya tous les services qui
concourent à la sécurité et les autres
services qui concourent au déplacement
parmi ceux qui concourent à la sécurité
vous avez les services locaux bien
évidemment compétences avec la
profiteurs de prise seul sur
l'agglomération parisienne
ça va être les services de police ou de
gendarmerie en un département province
et les autres services du palais c'est
par exemple le service de l'intendance
au service de l'ue de bizet le service
presse en fait la chefferie cabinet
c'est le chef d'orchestre des
déplacements du présent d'un public
monsieur benalla officier toujours sous
l'autorité du chef de cabinet ça veut
dire que par exemple avec les autres
services faisant en sorte effectivement
que le podium propre résidence au bien
installé en lisant un clodo visuel que
le pupitre soit bien là que les les élus
soient bien à l'accueil et c'est que la
presse soit bien là quand il fallait que
la presse soit là voilà l'ensemble de ce
que vous avez connu
vous connaissez dans les départements
dans lesquels vous êtes à ce titre étant
le chef d'orchestre il n'avait aucune
autorité directe sur les services de
sécurité
[Musique]
que ce soit sur le gspm est entendue où
que ce soit sur les services compétents
territorialement qui sont sous
l'autorité du préfet de département ou
du préfet de police pour ce qui concerne
l'agglomération parisienne 1 ceci étant
dit sa fonction de coordination dans le
cadre de l'organisation des déplacements
pouvait avoir des conséquences en
matière d'évolution du dispositif
quand il y avait des cas non conforme
qui se présentait par exemple on avait
des élus qui étaient pas qui était pas
le il fallait faire temporiser un petit
peu le séquençage quand y avait des
séquences qui est un peu raccourci
d'autres qui sont un petit peu bakli
qu'il faut sauter parce que ça prend
plus de temps
les journalistes qui sont pas là où il
faut ou alors on leur rajoute une petite
séquence voilà tout ça
effectivement en tant que chef
d'orchestre il donnait les consignes
sous l'autorité du chef de cabinet et
les tous les services qui concourent au
déplacement mais s'articuler de manière
à répondre à cette orientation à ses
orientations
les deuxièmes le deuxième volet de sa
mission ne ses prérogatives
c'était l'organisation des déplacements
non-officiel du président de république
toujours sur le volet organisationnel
les visites de reconnaissance le contact
et les actes interlocuteurs que
rencontrer le président le lien avec le
président pour tous qu'ils étaient pour
tous par rapport à ces différents
souhaits et là aussi son rôle est un
rôle de chef d'orchestre
sachant que la partie sécurité incombe
en propre en matière d'exécutions aux
j'espère sous mon autorité
[Musique]
le troisième volet qui ne rendent pas
qui est pas en lien direct avec les
missions du j'espère c'était la gestion
des invitations pour le 14 juillet donc
voilà les trois volets de sa mission
sous l'autorité du chef de cabinet
jusqu'au 1er mai 2018 et lieu les
événements que l'on connaît il ya des
périodes de suspension et au retour à
son retour au palais à compter du 22 mai
2018 il ya eu un recentrage de ses
missions dont qu'il avait toujours la
gestion des habitations du 14 juillet
est toujours organisation des
dépassements non-officiel du président
mais pour tout ce qui concerne les
déplacements officiels du président mais
il ne participait plus est ces missions
ont été recentrés ont été recentrés par
le directeur de cabinet sur des missions
au sein du palais de l'elysée comme
l'organisation des réceptions
l'organisation de réunions importantes
etc etc
voilà un petit peu la description que je
peux faire des relations je veux dire
fonctionnelle entre monsieur benalla
sous l'autorité du chef de cabine et ça
j'y tiens beaucoup
est ce que monsieur b n'est là
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
était quelqu'un de contrôler et il
officiait sous l'autorité directe du
chef de cabine après au niveau des
relations
moi je n'ai j'ai toujours entretenu en
tant que chef de service une excellente
relation avec monsieur bénard
c'est quelqu'un qui était dévoué
disponible réactif opérationnels sont
dans ces métiers dans son métier
organisation dans nos trente nous
entretenait d'excellentes relations
également sur le plan humain et c'est le
cas aussi avec mes collaborateurs et mes
collaborateurs ici présent en tant
qu'adjoint donc le volet professionnel
le volet relationnel fonctionnel
relationnel après vous avez évoqué
également là que je cite sur la place
publique
monsieur benalla faisait tahour effet et
à une relation tendue il alors moi il ne
me semble pas avoir entendu monsieur
benalla dire qu'il y avait des role of
qu'ils avaient des relations tendues
avec le avec avec le j'espère je pense
que c'est plutôt d'autres personnes qui
ont parlé de relations tendues avec le
j'espère de potentiel relations tendues
si on connaît le jeu faisait référence
aux propos de monsieur benalla dans le
journal du dimanche hier est également
dans le monde
admettant des frictions mais voilà et
des non-dits bon mais nous entendons
votre témoignage bien sûr est-ce que
vous avez achevé ce propos liminaire au
monsieur le président merci mon colonel
vous nous avez indiqué que monsieur
benalla ne participait plus aux
déplacements officiels du président de
la république après la reprise de ses
fonctions à l'elysée
pourtant il est à peu près à demi
maintenant qu'il était voyez même pas à
peu près il est complètement visible
qu'il accompagnait le président à
giverny comme à la cérémonie d'entrer au
panthéon de madame veil de sons et de
son époux ce qui signifie quand même
qu'il continuait à apporter un certain
concours et dont je ne sais pas
exactement la nature à ses déplacements
à l'extérieur mais laissons cela de côté
e la première question que j'ai eu envie
de vous poser je vois bien qu'il y avait
dans la définition de fonction en
quelque sorte dans la fiche de poste ces
trois dimensions elles nous ont été
également exposé par le directeur du
cabinet du président de la république et
nous aurions été surpris que vous ayez
une vision différente de ce qui était la
description de sa fonction mais il est
aussi important pour nous d'essayer de
mesurer quelle était l'importance
respective de ces trois fonctions
nous le voyons souvent dans les
déplacements officiels n'ont pas dans la
participation à l'organisation mais
dans une présence qui évoque une
fonction de protection rapprochée qui
n'entre pas dans cette définition de
fonction mais dont on peut concevoir que
sans avoir eu à l'écrire dans la fiche
de poste et il était convenu qu'en
raison de son expérience dans ce domaine
il remplissait aux côtés de vos propres
votre propre équipe de vos propres
équipes une fonction de protection comme
il était par ailleurs titulaire d'un
port d'armes
ex port d'armes a été justifiée par le
préfet de police par les fonctions de
police qu'il exerçait nous sommes
également demandé si cette arme qu'il
portait n'apportez pas essentiellement
pour accompagner les déplacements privés
du président et ceux ci évoquerez
également cette fonction pour parler
simplement avec des mots de tous les
jours deux gardes du corps
je voudrais que vous puissiez nous
indiquer puisque vos collaborateurs
même dans les déplacements privés sont
également amenés
heureusement d'ailleurs assurer la
sécurité du président de la république
si c'est une vision fausse que j'énonce
aussi c'est une vision exacte
[Musique]
non monsieur le président il ya
plusieurs plusieurs sous question dans
votre question je vais je vais tâcher
d'y répondre la manière la plus la plus
claire la plus exhaustive
je vais revenir au départ chronologique
sur sur giverny et et le panthéon
giverny était un déplacement non
officielle du président tout à l'heure
j'ai rappelé que monsieur benalla était
toujours en charge après à compter du 22
mai des déplacements non-officiel du
président donc là c'est pas une surprise
qu'il était présent en termes
d'organisation dans ce déplacement la
concernant le panthéon le panthéon est
un était un événement d'ampleur pour la
présence de république et donc pour la
chefferie
je m'exprimais j'ai pas mr et oh au
titre et à la place mais évidemment du
chef de cabinet mais la vision j'en ai
effectivement déplacement d'ampleur tous
les moyens de la chefferie de cabinet
sont mobilisés et il a été mobilisé
à ce titre là puisque les quatre
personnels de la chefferie cabinet l'été
pour cet événement d'emploi comme ce fut
le cas d'ailleurs pour le 14 juillet
voilà pour donner quelques précisions
donc il ya rien rien d'étrange tout est
explicable et très clairement
y at il une importance respective dans
ces trois fonctions tout ça dépend des
déplacements du président très
clairement ça dépend le 14 juillet c'est
une fois puis après déplacements et plus
déplacement officiel que déplacements
des officiels dont l'importance est liée
aux déplacements
en tant que tel du président de
république après vous avez dit s'il me
permettre qu'il était convenu qu'il
remplisse aux côtés des deux équipes des
fonctions de protection
monsieur benalla comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure ne dirigeait pas le j'espère et
n'occuper aucune fonction de protection
du président république
puis à voir vous pouvez avoir une
confusion effectivement il a je vous
apporter une précision dans les images
que vous certaines images que vous avez
pu voir de monsieur benalla en action il
faut différencier ces images mehdi et
durant la période la période où il était
c'était pendant la campagne électorale
de la période à compter de l'investiture
du 14 mai 2010 est à compter du 14 mai
2010 est moi je peux pas parler de la
parenté puisque je n'ai pas vécu ce que
gt gt en fonction à auge espère sous le
sceau président hollande mais à compter
du 14 mai 2017
nous avons eu des évolutions en matière
d'organisation et les évolutions
opérationnelles en liaison avec le chef
de cabinet c'est pour cette raison que
monsieur benalla comme les autres
membres de la chefferie cabinet et comme
d'autres membres des différents services
qui concourent à l'organisation et au
bon déroulement de dépassement des
programmes publics
on était doté d'équipements radio sauf
que les équipements radio je vais faire
je vais schématiser nous on a notre
propre bulle radio sécurité et donc on à
moi j'ai consenti en lisant que chef de
cabinet à dédier des équipements radio
sur un autre canal complètement
différent pour permettre au canal
organisation de pouvoir travailler
ensemble concrètement parlant à vous et
le chef de cabinet qui est en liaison et
que l'attachée de presse qui gère le
pool presse avec le photographe par
rapport à son positionnement en liaison
avec avec les différentes avec le
protocole etc etc
concrètement il ya un certain nombre de
personnes qui aient disposé de radio
sous l'égide du chef de cabinet de
manière à faire en sorte notamment dans
des déplacements ou qui nécessitent pas
le déplacement physique parce que si on
a un dépassement physique de telle ou
telle entité telle ou telle personne
comprendrez aisément que ça des
structures un petit peu organisation
donc ça permettait aux chefs de cabine
et de pouvoir coordonner avec la
communication l'audiovisuel le
photographe s'était rang de coordonner
leur négation même du des places
et donc de ne pas pénaliser aussi la
sécurité tout ça travaillant de manière
la plus cohérente possible donc une
bulle sécurité une bulle organisation et
de bulles complètement étanche en fait
la seule personne qui écoute qui écoute
l'autre bull c'est le chef du j'espère
en fait moi je suis responsable de la
bulle sécurité mais j'écoute la bulle
organisation pour pouvoir trouver cette
cohérence là et donc monsieur benalla
quand on le voit notamment au salon de
l'agriculture avec une oreillette
c'est une oreillette pour la bulle
organisation et pas pour la partie
sécurité et son positionnement physique
est là pour comme pour le chef de
cabinet vous riad au dépassement du
président le chef de cabinet ou selon le
chef adjoint de cabinet sont là pour
être populaire de prison pour le tirer
et pour faire en sorte qu'ils en
prennent bien le chemin qui soit celui
qu'on est prévue pendant la mission de
reconnaissance et également pour
recueillir ses observations aussi ses
souhaits de pouvoir changer un moment
donné de cheminement et auquel kb nous
avertir ni lentilles 1b rue des
dentelles stand 6 7 l/100 il à dentelles
stands donc là ça me permet de pardon de
nour est articulé voilà ça c'est
totalement explicable sur le plan
technique
et voilà pourquoi il porter une
oreillette merci et le port d'armes
pour ce qui me concerne je n'ai jamais
vu monsieur benalla avec une arme dans
les dépassements du présent à public ça
c'est pour ce qui vous concerne pas ce
que vous avez des membres du groupe de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république qui ont eu à accompagner le
président de la république et en même
temps que le faisait monsieur benalla et
qui ont constaté qu'il portait une arme
je n'ai eu aucun retour en ce sens
merci mon colonel
est-ce que c'est madame jourdain
monsieur sur notre dame jourda merci
monsieur président colonel nous essayons
vous l'avez compris de de consigne est
de confronter différentes informations
qui nous parviennent pour qu'elle ait un
sens bon ce qui n'est pas toujours le
cas notamment nous avons entendu mais
vous le savez les syndicats de police
qui faisait état des relations
difficiles il avait utilisé un terme
beaucoup plus fort il avait utilisé pour
certains avec ces crabes entre monsieur
benalla et les policiers avec lesquels
il travaillait et nous avons monsieur
bédard a lui-même qui admet que les
relations étaient difficiles aussi à
mieux j'espère en parlant notamment de
friction ce sont des articles qui sont
parus auquel il a été fait allusion tout
à l'heure vous nous indiquez que vous
même et vos collaborateurs n'avaient pas
connu ce type de difficultés pour
relations étaient bonnes alors quand
vous parlez de vos collaborateurs vous
parlez de vos collaborateurs proches ou
de l'intégralité de vos hommes ceux qui
sont sous votre commandement
si tel est le cas c'est à dire si
l'intégralité des sommes qui sont sous
votre commandement n'ont pas de
difficulté avec monsieur bella comment
expliquez vous ces propos tenus à la
fois par lui par les syndicats monsieur
mon colonel pardon madame l'accord a
pour toi je vais me permettre une
précision inc est une question avant de
vous répondre
[Musique]
par rapport à la mission de la mission
de la commission de votre commission qui
est qui et de devoir citer personne
n'ayant pas n'étant pas au sens pas
partie des fonds sécurité intérieure ont
pu ou peuvent participer à des missions
de protection ce qui est le rapport
entre les relations et des munitions des
personnes qui participent à des missions
de protection
si vous pouvez m'expliquer quand je
puisse répondre s'il vous plaît alors il
s'avère que ce sont plutôt nous qui
posons des questions que les personnes
qui sont auditionnés pour autant de ce
que j'entendais de ce que vous avez dit
vous indiquer que monsieur benalla était
amené à donner des consignes dans son
rôle de coordination
on a pu le voir notamment dans une vidéo
qui a été récemment publiée par un
syndicat de police s'exprimer lors du
retour des bleus à l'égard de policiers
d'une façon assez raide
si je puis dire est ce que ces consignes
n'ont pas pu être je dirais interprétées
comme des ordres à l'égard des membres
du j'espère qu'ils n'ont pas d'ordre à
recevoir du coordinateur
c'était ça le sens de ma question entre
tous je jouais remercie madame c'est
beaucoup plus clair pour moi pour
pouvoir répondre alors déjà je ne
commenterai absolument pas les propos
tenus par les
pour les collègues du syndicat de police
c'est n'appartient pas de les commenter
j'ai bien évidemment la visite
personnelle que je ne fournirai pas ici
mais je ne commenterai pas et je ne
commenterai pas non plus les propos
tenus par monsieur b dallas puisque la
paternité lui leur revient puis je suis
passé dans sa tête
ceci étant dit le correspondant dans
dans ce que je décrivais tout à l'heure
dans l'émission le correspondant naturel
du chef de cabinet ou de ses adjoints
c'est le chef du j'espère donc à la
limite si quelqu'un avait eu à se
plaindre de parole un peu plus véhémente
autant du c'est moi ou mes adjoints -
titre personnel sur bennane m'a jamais
mal par les autres bien au contraire
après on imagine vous imaginez bien que
dans les déplacements des foyers moments
de tension on va pas forcément prendre
toutes les télés tous les
circonvolutions de courtoisie parce
qu'il faut que ça aille vite et que cela
et que ce soit très réactif
donc effectivement le chef de cabinet ou
seront ses adjoints ne s'adresse pas
mais personnel directement parce que
c'est un rôle d'organisation donc le
chef d'orchestre de chef d'orchestre il
s'occupe
il s'adresse aux par exemple aux
pochettes des violons etc et et il
s'adresse aux chefs du j'espère et c'est
celle du j'espère qui traduit en termes
opérationnels les instructions du chef
de cabinet adjoint
bien évidemment si monsieur bénard où le
chef de cabinet ou le chef adjoint de
cabinet s'adresser directement à un
personnel ça me paraîtrait quand même
très étrange ce qui n'est absolument pas
le cas parce que le seul à voir la
vision globale de la posture de sécurité
adoptée c'est celle d'une action
j'espère dans l'émission donc le chef de
cabinet ou monsieur bnl en concurrence
parce que on parle de lui s'adresse aux
chefs du j'espère ou à ses adjoints
il ya voilà ce serait bien de faire ça
et on le met en musique sur le plan
opérationnel
mais moi j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas eu
de retour particulier
indiquant une attitude particulière ou
vainement de monsieur benallal manière
récurrente
d'ailleurs si je me souviens bien si je
me souviens bien là vous allez poser une
question aux syndicats de police en
demandant leurs sources a abandonné 6 et
donc c'est des sources locales
correspondants locaux du service de la
protection
il me semble que le chef du fmi le chef
du sdl béni le directeur général de la
police nationale nous sommes de retour
dans ce sens là ni moi-même bien
évidemment étant sous l'autorité
organique du chef du slp donc c'est donc
moi je suis très preneur d'avoir ce type
de retour là parce que peut-être que les
gens ont mal senties mais moi une
personne n'a fait le venu me le dire
très bien un preneur de je suis très
preneur cilicie à des retours merci mon
colonel de bien nous sommes nous aussi
très preneur d'information madame jourda
merci monsieur le président colonel vous
nous avez indiqué tout à l'heure que
seul le j'espère été chargé de la
protection du président de la république
avant vous nous avons auditionné
monsieur le préfet de police des bouches
du rhône qui nous indiquait qu'à une
reprise lors d'un déplacement public du
président de la république il avait vu
monsieur benalla en protection face à la
foule
à l'instar des autres membres des
membres plutôt du gspr alors je
souhaiterais savoir qu'à la réflexion ça
vous inspire
et surtout si il n'est pas possible
c'est une hypothèse je n'en fais qu'une
hypothèse
lorsqu'il y a précisément des mots des
moments de tension comme vous l'indiquez
dans les manifestations que monsieur
benalla prennent de fait le rôle d'un
membre de la protection du président de
la république en colonel madame dans les
moments de
je fais attention au terme dans les
moments de tension c'est pas tensions
entre le j'espère monsieur b n'est là
c'est dans les moments de tension dans
le cadre du déplacement dans les moments
de tension
j'irai le dispositif du j'espère reste
au à la main du j'espère le déficit de
sécurité restent à la main du chef du
j'espère il est bien évident mais là on
parle de monsieur b dallas mais c'est le
cas pour le chef de cabinet pour le chef
adjoint de cabinet que lorsqu'on a des
mouvements de foule et qu' il ya
nécessité est bien le chef de cabinet ou
en l'occurrence monsieur benalla ne va
pas s'effacer physiquement gérard y
participent
ils vont donner un peu plus de fluidité
c'est évident quand vous avez des gens
qui se présentent devant pour venir
parler au président vous avez aussi un
filtrage de lapin du chef de cabinet qui
autorise ou pas de fêtes 2,2 aux
personnes de pouvoir accéder au
président donc oui ça peut donner cette
impression mais dans les faits ces
actions pas le cas merci de votre
réponse je précise je précise quand même
que c'est
je précise là on parle de monsieur
bénard mais c'est le code tous les
membres de la chefferie cabinet sac
abandonné en cas de nécessité mais
également ils vont un peu plus poussée
ça se voit par exemple henri culture on
peut prendre d'autres images où monsieur
loge fait aussi 7 à cette posture c'est
normal c'est pas c'est pas illogique
mais ils font pas partie de la bulle de
sécurité
madame jourda ses présidences heures mon
colonel
je voulais vous féliciter pour commencer
pour votre placidité parce que
naturellement le monsieur benalla ne
s'exprime pas exactement dans les mêmes
termes
quand vous lisez le journal paru hier il
dit par exemple gspr et l'enfant
terrible de l'elysée nous donnait pas
permettez moi de vous le dire
l'impression d'être le chef d'un enfant
terrible de l'elysée peut-être monsieur
l'adjoint peut-être que je me trompe
mais je n'ai pas ce sentiment
il parle de friction de non dits il
parle d' incohérences totalement
incroyable s'agissant du gspr 1 re lisez
l'article il dit voilà il faut une autre
organisation
donc il semble être chargés de réfléchir
une autre organisation
mais il nous dit il y à un acteur qui
est content radicalement compte c'est le
ministère de l'intérieur quand même un
représentant du cabinet du président de
la république qui dit comme ça c'est
chose à l'égard du ministère de
l'intérieur ça pose quand même quelques
problèmes et la théorie que vous nous
expliquer vraiment vous l'expliquer avec
je crois beaucoup de clarté en vertu de
laquelle monsieur e benalla n'aurait pas
de missions de sécurité
elle est quand même battu en brèche par
le fait il à vous le savez un port de
police considérant c'est écrit sur le
document que monsieur benalla exerce des
missions de police pas de ses grilles de
police et vous avez des ports de police
cher cher collègue mais chacun a
rectifié lanjard merci andré bien sûr et
bien sûr et d'autre part j'imagine que
par rapport à vos subordonnés hommes et
des femmes qui je dois le dire assure
une mission extrêmement difficile très
très difficile
votre mission
ce qui se passe le 1er mai lorsque c'est
connu ça ne doit pas complètement les
réjouir enfin que quelqu'un qui n'a
aucune attribution de police se comporte
de cette manière que peut-être ce ne
soit pas la seule fois dans la journée
puisqu'on a eu un autre témoignage
tout cela pose quand même problème une
fois que ces faits ont eu lieu qui ont
une certaine gravité dont beaucoup
pensent qu'ils eussent dû être donné
lieu à une saisine de la justice dès le
2 mai revient et exerce des missions
très notoire très visible est ce que ça
ne pose quand même pas des problèmes
est ce que ce n'est pas perçue par vos
hommes et vos deux femmes d'une manière
problématique et enfin je termine j'ai
qu'une seule question
on a eu le sentiment peut-être à tort
que monsieur benalla était une sorte de
garde du corps ce que nous a dit le
préfet de police des bouches du rhône
par rapport aux déplacements privés
corrobore cela le fait qu'il dise
lui-même qu'il n'utilise son arme il
n'utilise son arme que pour les
déplacements privés ce qui prouve que
pour les déplacements privés
il a une arme et il pense qu'il est
légitime qu'il y ait une arme et s'il
est légitime qu'il y ait une arme c'est
pour qu'on puisse éventuellement s'en
servir et on est donc dans la sécurité
ou dans la police
donc est ce que tout cela ne crée pas
une confusion et enfin j'ai eu
l'occasion très souvent pour des
situations que j'ai vécue comme élu
voyez vous de voir de très près ce que
c'est que la protection rapprochée
vous l'avez vu mille fois plus que moi
et je pense à une grande fête à laquelle
je participe chaque année depuis 37 ans
et où vous avez une personnalité ce
quatre ou cinq fois le président de la
république qui se promènent sur 4 5 km
dans une rue où il ya plein de monde
mais je vois ce que c'est que votre
travail à 20 cm 30 cm 40 cm et quand
vous avez quelqu'un qui est toujours là
et qui à côté et qui n'a pas de
sion de police et de sécurité est ce que
ça ne finit pas par créer un problème ou
pas reconstituer même un obstacle à
certains égards par rapport à votre
professionnalisme que je tiens encore
une fois saluer c'est ma seule question
je reconnais qu'elle est peu développée
il ya plusieurs questions rituelles et
développer mais je n'en donnerai je n'en
passerait pas plus mon colonel vous avez
la parole
je sénateurs si je si j'oublie une
question nommé rôle selon leurs aveux
[Musique]
vous comprendrez aisément mesdames
messieurs que je peux pas je peux
m'exprimer pas sûr je rapporterai pas le
sentiment des femmes et des hommes du
j'espère concernant l'effet du mime et
ça ça leur appartient
comme mon appréciation personnelle c'est
évident mais évidemment c'est je dirais
juste que
c'est une faute la fota les graves et
qu'elle ait pris en tant que tel mais
qui a été prise en tant que tel le reste
faisant le faisant l'objet de
l'information judiciaire en quelque
chose ces références tout est là sur les
propos tenus par part donc monsieur
benalla d'engins le dimanche je les ai
pas vues sur l'enfant terrible de nous
intéresser davantage aux travaux de
notre commission que aux articles de
presse manifestement parce que ça fait
chaud alésia les signé jeudi je dirais
que je dirais que le dimanche je me
repose sur un président effectivement et
de sortie de ces propos n'appartiennent
qu'à lui
très clairement sur les frictions les
non-dits là aussi ces propos
n'appartiennent qu'à lui moi je très
clairement je pense que s'il y avait des
soucis au sein du j'espère je pense que
j'en aurais eu déjà des retours depuis
plus d'un an et demi que je commande le
j'espère mais comme pour qu'on pourrait
dire en somme que de votre point de vue
s'il y avait des frictions elle ne
dépassait pas les tensions normal qu'il
y a dans toute organisation de travail
et que vous n'avez donc pas eu à
reconnaître dans dans un système humain
il ya forcément des frictions mais le
monde n'est pas parfait bien évidemment
comme l'y aider effectivement on forme
une équipe au sein des alizés c'est des
équipes constituent c'est comme un sport
collectif dans un sport collectif
effectivement des fois il ya des petites
tensions mais le but c'est que l'effet
final soit sur le meilleur possible
très clairement mais effectivement ça
n'est pas les frictions moi je n'avais
pas connu jambes que j'en connais pas de
deux très importantes qui mériterait
effectivement d'être mis sur la place
publique
très clairement compris permettez moi y
compris dans la mise en oeuvre de la
protection rapprochée
si quelqu'un est là très proche ça pose
pas de problème ça n'a jamais posé de
problème je je je prêt je reprécise
monsieur rapporteur que monsieur benalla
en tant que chef j'espère moi en tant
que chef du j'espère je précise que
monsieur benalla ne faisait pas de
missions de protection et que l'attitude
qu'il a pu avoir à un moment donné était
liée à sa fonction au sein de la
chefferie cabinet j'ai expliqué
notamment l'oreillette
pourquoi la proximité pourquoi voilà
j'ai bien expliqué techniquement donc là
moi je peux pas vous en dire plus non
ils étaient pas il faisait pas partie du
j'espère il ne dirigeait pas le j'espère
qu'il n'avait pas de fonctions de
sécurité au j'espère je n'ai jamais vu
quel que soit le déplacement avec une
arme et moi j'aime eu aucun retour dix
ans monsieur ben ali est armé à
l'occasion d'un déplacement présidentiel
très bien eh bien je vais donner la
parole à monsieur françois pilet merci
monsieur président en colonel je vous
posais des questions qui sont totalement
différentes l'une de l'autre et qui sont
semble-t-il assez précise vous assurez
la une fonction extrêmement importante
la sécurité du président de la
république donc vous devez avoir une
connaissance totale connaissance totale
de l'inventaire de toutes les armes de
quelque nature qu'elles soient qui sont
détenus à l'elysée yat-il hors des
post-it des policiers ou gendarmes et or
de monsieur benalla d'autres personnes
titulaires d'un port d'armes aux
détentrices d'armes à l'elysée ma
première question la seconde on a vu sur
benalla et d'autres se répandre sur la
réorganisation des services assurant la
sécurité de l'elysée et du président
pourquoi cette réorganisation
et s'il ya eu des incidents qui la
légitime ce que semble dire
indirectement monsieur benalla mais
pourquoi réorganiser quelque chose dont
a priori on pense que tout fonctionnait
très bien
quand colonel
concernant la les personnes qui
pouvaient être qu'ils peuvent être
détentrice terme faut différencier les
différentes natures de détention d'armes
je vous avoue que sur les 800
fonctionnaires à l'elysée je ne connais
pas toutes celles qui font du tir
sportif c'est
voilà ça reste ça relève de leur vie
privée
très clairement la pratique du tir
sportif
monsieur bédard avait avait un port dans
madame la sénatrice avait un port
d'armes délivrée par le préfet de police
là on parle de détention manière
générique de magna bourdin ou détention
moi à ma connaissance
à ma connaissance il ya uniquement
effectivement monsieur benalla de par
son port d'armes ainsi que les
militaires de la guerre des prix ken du
conte en militaire mais là je parlerai
pas au nom du général bio-farina mais je
pense que je peux me permettre
concernant la détention d'armes et les
fonctionnaires et militaires du j'espère
qu'ils sont qui sont porteurs de leurs
hommes dans et qui exercent des missions
de police et de sécurité de protection
les autres des temps les autres
personnels j'en ai pas connaissance
mon colonel
ce qui est très compliqué pour nous
c'est de voir à quel point les
appréciations peuvent être différentes
entre les uns et les autres et parce que
le préfet de police a eu entre les mains
de contrat de travail liant monsieur
benalla avec les services de la
présidence de la république pour une
mission de coordination de la sécurité
avec les forces militaires et groupe de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république il a été attentif à
l'attestation de formation continue qui
a pu être délivrés par le major de
police en charge de la cellule formation
du groupe de sécurité de la présidence
de la république ainsi que les carnets
tirage ou reproduit pour monsieur
benalla il vise ces documents dans sa
décision
ensuite il relève que monsieur benalla
est chargé d'une mission de police dans
le cadre de son action de coordination
de la sécurité de la présidence de la
république avec les forces militaires et
le gspr je pense que les forces
militaires s'avise le commandant
militaire du palais
de l'elysée est ensuite mentionne le
haut niveau de menace terroriste et la
sensibilité du domaine d'exercice de sa
mission et il arrête ensuite la décision
qui n'est pas une décision permettant à
monsieur benalla simplement de continuer
à pratiquer le tir sportif et c'est
étonnant que vous n'ayez pas été alors
que votre service est mentionné à
plusieurs reprises dans l'arrêté
autorisant le port d'armes du préfet de
police c'est étonnant que vous n'ayez
pas été aucun moment relation avec la
préfecture de police au moment de la
délivrance de ce permis de port d'armé
et que vous puissiez nous dire
aujourd'hui que vous n'en aviez même pas
connaissance et qui puisait que vous
même n'avez jamais été informé par l'un
de vos agents d'avoir participé à une
mission au cours de laquelle monsieur
benalla aurait porté une arme
si vous voulez pour pour pour nous c'est
très difficile d'y voir clair
parce que nous ne demandons qu'à vous
croire bien sûr et vous avez prêté
serment et en même temps nous avons là
des décisions du préfet de police qui
ont une tout autre interprétation de la
mission de monsieur benalla et par
ailleurs nous avons quelques indices qui
évoque une mission de protection que
monsieur benalla semble également avoir
eu pendant la campagne présidentielle
et nous disons vraiment avec un minimum
de bon sens qui peut être démentie par
la preuve contraire j'en conviens qu'il
ya une sorte de continuité dans le
travail de monsieur benalla au fond les
raisons pour laquelle pour lesquels il a
pu être appréciée pendant la campagne
présidentielle sont aussi les raisons
pour lesquelles il a été recruté qu'il
ya bien sûr une définition de fonction
qui correspondent à de nouvelles
missions mais que
il ya une sorte de permanence dans la
mission personnelle en quelque sorte de
de monsieur benalla auprès d'abord du
candidat puis du président de la
république en outre je relève que le
chef du service de la protection nous a
indiqué qu' il était quant à lui
fermement opposé au port d'armes par
monsieur benalla craignant une
interférence avec le groupe de
protection du groupe de sécurité de la
présidence de la république
donc il semble bien que en ce qui le
concerne le chef du service lui avait
tout de même connaissance de cette de
cette question du port d'armé par
monsieur bénard voilà ce que je veux
vous dire nous avons du mal à établir la
vérité et face à ces discordances
je comprends tout à fait mais je vais
revenir sur la question monsieur le
sénateur monsieur saint thomas poser la
question de savoir si je connaissais
d'autres détenteurs de port d'armes aux
remuants en pot en citant il a cité
monsieur bénin
donc en plus de ces bien répondu en plus
de monsieur benalla cas l'autorisation
des militaires de galp lichens et des
fonctionnaires qui travaillent au
j'espère je ne connais pas d'autres
personnes qui sont titulaires d'un port
d'armes j'aime bien j'ai bien répondre à
la question mais vous saviez donc que
monsieur b d'alameda de la question
d'abîmer alors maintenant je vous en
pose une autre puisque lé vous saviez
que monsieur benalla avec une
autorisation de porter une arme
oui j'étais au courant mais j'étais
j'avais pas j'étais pas au courant je
vais pas l'arrêter j'avais il ya une
autorisation mais j'avais pas l'arrêter
avec l'élimination exactement merci de
votre réponse monsieur pilet oui pardon
mon colonel s'il vous plaît allez y s'il
vous plaît donc je le peux je le précise
et comme j'ai prêté serment je vous dis
très clairement les yeux dans les yeux
je n'ai jamais vu monsieur benalla avec
une âme dans les déplacements du prise
en main que j'ai aucun retour de
fonctionnaires dans les déplacements
pendant tous les déplacements y compris
privés oui dans les déplacements que
soit officielle ou non officiels la
question qu'on se pose est alors c'est
pourquoi pourquoi la présidence de la
république at elle souhaité que monsieur
benalla
une un permis de port d'armes peut-être
que vous ne pouvez pas répondre à cette
question et je ne vous en voudrez pas de
ne pas le faire enfin il a bien fallu
que
la présidence interviennent pour qu'il
obtienne ce port d'armes à raison des
fonctions qu'il exerçait à la présidence
si vous me permettez vous avez
auditionné déjà pas mal de pas mal de
personnes qui ont répondu me semble-t-il
sur la sur l'instruction de concevoir la
délivrance et l'autorisation du port
soit le préfet de police ou les
directeurs de cabinet de présenter
public donc moi je peux vous du point de
vue du j'espère par rapport à ce que
j'ai constaté
est ce que j'ai vécu au quotidien
puisque j'accompagne quasiment
quotidiens le présent avis public je
n'ai pas vu monsieur b dallas avec une
arme qu'ils soient mariés déplacement
officiel honda officielle du présent et
public
[Musique]
je vous pencher sur sénateurs seront eu
jeu précise que monsieur benalla a
déclaré portait son arme lors des
déplacements privés il l'a déclaré dans
la presse monsieur co-rapporteur s'il a
déclaré donc si le prétend moi je n'ai
je n'ai pas constaté qu'il avait d'armes
je ne peux pas je ne peux pas le dire
autrement nous vous en donnons acte tout
à fait monsieur mon colonel
poursuivez mon colonel
concernant là ça rejoint aussi une autre
question vous avez posé sur laquelle le
co-rapporteur ge
ça permettrait de répondre le fait une
réponse conjointe concernant le projet
de réorganisation de la sécurité là
aussi vous permettrez nous permettrait
une remarque liminaire
je sais pas si ça rentre complètement
dans le champ de la de la commission je
pense que oui mon colonel
d'accord mais vous comprendrez quand
même que pour des raisons de sécurité et
par rapport aux propos liminaire que
j'ai que j'ai eu tout à l'heure je crois
pas m'appesantir sur 7 sur cette
réflexion mais évidemment je dirais que
ce projet-là cette réflexion là ce n'est
absolument pas la passion pas pour but
de créer une sorte d'officine privée
d'une garde prétorienne l'espère bien
mais je mais je préfère le dire et c'est
moi qui le dit mais une fois qu'on a dit
ça
très clairement il faut savoir que cette
direction de la sécurité de la preuve de
présence de république c'est une
réflexion qui a pour but de rapprocher
les deux services qui assurent la
sécurité de la présidence à l'extérieur
pour j'espère et à l'intérieur pour le
corps militaire des incohérences dont on
ti auquel il fait allusion
c'est pas les incohérences au sein du
j'espère c'est les incohérences éventuel
au sein de l'un d'eux la sécurité de
manière générale effectivement on a
jusqu'à présent un codé compétences
intérieur compétences extérieures le but
c'est non pas de faire une fusion comme
je l'aï entendu mais de créer une vraie
synergie entre les services en charge de
la sécurité en direct du président
république et de la présence de
république
cette réflexion dont le but est à la
fois l'efficience une meilleure
cohérence par rapport à ce que je disais
également s'inscrit dans un projet plus
global de transformation de l'ensemble
des services de la présidence
le squattage général la présidence le
directeur qui vit à présent cependant
l'on évoqué c'est pas simplement un
projet de transformation des services de
sécurité c'est un projet plus global de
transformation et services la présence
dans l'esprit du grand public et dans ce
projet là il ya le volet sécurité et le
but également en plus de l'efficacité
c'est d'avoir une plus grande lisibilité
et une plus grande sincérité sur le plan
budgétaire aussi la cour des comptes a
reproché depuis des années à l'elysée
son manque de clarté par rapport à
l'imputation budgétaires en matière de
sécurité
l'unss aussi l'occasion effectivement
d'être très claires et d'avoir un budget
propre sur lequel on puisse dire mais
telle action de sécurité sac ou de temps
pour faire ça d'ailleurs je je souligne
qu' il me semble que la semaine dernière
la cour des comptes dans un communiqué à
a dit tout le bien qu'elle pensait de
ses réformes de services en partie de la
sécurité ça allait dans le bon sens
cette réflexion est piloté par le
général bio farina et j'en suis le co
pilote
là aussi autant monsieur benalla ne
dirigez pas le j'espère ne dirigeait pas
le chrono militaire ne digérait pas ne
dirigeait pas la sécurité autant
monsieur benalla canton comme on a pu le
dire il ya une dizaine de jours ne
pilotez pas cette réforme là monsieur b
dallas par rapport à sa position au sein
de la chefferie cabinet a participé en
tant que besoin à des groupes de travail
puisque nous sommes actuellement la
conduite du changement
on a constitué des groupes de travail
avec des fonctionnaires concernés du
j'espère du conte en militaires
effectivement on réfléchit à la
meilleure manière de conduire le
changement parce qu'on a besoin de
changement parce qu'on va conduire
effectivement les personnels ça va aller
ça va on va aller vers une nouvelle
organisation
cette réflexion en battant la nouvelle
organisation donc il faut préparer les
personnels et les fait adhérer à ce
projet là en tenant compte de leur odeur
de leurs réflexions aussi
voilà ce que je peux dire sur le ce
projet-là cette réflexion-là qui a cours
et qui est évoquée également par le
secrétaire général de l'elysée et le
dialogue a dit madame jourdain une
question c'est un fait que vous puissiez
répondre sans trahir aucun secret il y a
donc un comité de pilotage qui a été
mise en place dans lequel monsieur
benalla a toute sa place ou unac des
interventions ponctuelles
[Musique]
là on touche l'organisation interne de
10 et le comité de pilotage vous le vous
l'avez vous l'avez lu lu dans la dans la
presse le leu leu ce binôme la pilote la
réflexion effectivement en tant que
besoin
monsieur bénard a insisté effectivement
la livre en vo de travail par exemple
donc dans le dans les réflexions
également il ya mon adjoint qui était
impliqué est l'adjoint du général buat
farhan haq a impliqué c'est normal c'est
évidemment logique question très simple
est ce que le ministère de l'intérieur
fait partie de ce groupe de pilotage et
ce qualité
monsieur co-rapporteur vous comprendrez
que il ne m'appartient pas de répondre à
cette question là je n'en suis que le co
pilote le tout ce travail de réflexion
effet sous l'égide du diatta cabinet de
la présidence républicaine et et d'eau
et donc le travail en synergie
bien évidemment avec le mistral
intérieur m'appartient pas forcément d'y
répondre ici monsieur mon colonel je le
comprends très bien votre réponse je me
permets de dire simplement à titre
personnel en tant que parlementaire que
la question de savoir si le ministère de
l'intérieur participent effectivement à
ce travail ou ne participe pas n'est pas
sans importance par rapport à
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics dans
notre pays
cette remarque t'appelles pas de réponse
évidemment nous avons d'ailleurs posé
pratiquement la même question au
directeur de cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur
tout à l'heure tu n'en es pas retenu
sous réserve de relire sa réponse le
sentiment que le ministère de
l'intérieur avait une part active cette
réflexion je donne la parole maintenant
à monsieur alain richard je vais faire
une observation de méthode qui va
peut-être avoir un peu d'utilité dans la
suite de nos débats
j'entends depuis maintenant fière cité
abondamment les déclarations faites par
monsieur benalla à la presse et
j'entends notamment le co rapporteur
jean-pierre sueur essayer de les opposer
aux déclarations qui sont faites par les
personnes que je nous auditionnons me
semble donc justifiée il me semble donc
justifier de souligner l'écart de statut
entre ces deux positions
monsieur benalla est une personne qui a
été licencié pour motif disciplinaire de
ses fonctions à l'elysée
et c'est une personne qui fait l'objet
d'une enquête judiciaire qui selon toute
vraisemblance se terminera dans un
nombre de mois a évalué devant le
tribunal correctionnel de paris
et donc les propos publics qui tient
relève un enfant de 8 ans comprend cela
d'une stratégie de défense personnelle
et j'observe aussi que les fait concret
démontrable qui sont cités dans ces
propos sont rarissimes
en revanche les hauts fonctionnaires
serviteur de l'état qui s'expriment
devant nous sous serment dans une
audience parlementaire s'exprime dans
des conditions extrêmement différentes
et donc je pense qu'il serait fâché
qu'au sein de la commission denquête
apparaissent une égalité de valeurs
entre les propos de l'un et des autres
nous remercient
mes chers collègues ce n'est pas parce
que nos collègues rapporteur ou moi même
ou d'autres collègues
posons des questions à partir des propos
de monsieur benalla que vous pouvez en
déduire que nous attachons la même
valeur à des propos tenus sous serment
par des hauts fonctionnaires et aux
propos de monsieur benalla simplement
monsieur benalla et peut-être assez bien
placé pour s'exprimer sur le travail
qu'il faisait et c'est intéressant se
trouve non pas d'opposer les uns aux
autres mais de faire la lumière à partir
de contradictions qui ont émergé et
d'ailleurs mon cher collègue ses
contradictions n'existe pas seulement
entre les propos de monsieur benalla et
les explications que nous recevons à la
commission j'ai dû tout à l'heure
l'arrêté du préfet de police nous a
aussi interrogé sur la nature exacte sur
la nature exacte de la fonction de
monsieur benalla subsiste quelques
interrogations il ne croit pas qu'il
soit mal venu de les soulever
précisément pour permettre aux personnes
auditionnées de les démentir
si elle mérite de l'être soviétique
alors monsieur le président sur man
notre collègue alain richard ayant bien
voulu me citer je tiens à préciser mon
total accord avec lui il n'y a pas dans
mon esprit de signe égal entre une
personne qui en est fait accompli des
actes dont devant cette commission
et vous pouvez m'en donner à mes chers
collègues j'ai à de nombreuses reprises
dit que comme l'a dit le président de la
république qui c'était inadmissible et
inacceptable et les fonctionnaires que
nous recevons les hauts fonctionnaires
et simplement
des déclarations qui sont faites dans la
presse ou dans les médias sont un fait
et ses déclarations
13 mai tout à fait nous nous ce n'est
peut-être pas si mon cher monsieur ben
ali compte tenu des conditions dans
lesquelles ces propos de matt et j de
défense est certainement qu'ils
cherchent à se présenter sous le
meilleur jour
alors qu'il a accompli des actes qui
sont inadmissibles et inacceptable mais
j'ajoute aussi pour être tout à fait
précis donc dans l'énoncé des questions
il est vrai que j ai fait allusion et je
le revends revendique la possibilité de
le faire mais que presque à chaque fois
quitte à être parfois un peu long j'ai
tenu à dire que toute notre admiration
et notre estime
pour les fonctionnaires de la police de
la gendarmerie des différents services
de sécurité est encore à l'instant pour
le gspr puisque j'ai témoigné et j'ai
dit l'immense difficulté est aussi
l'abnégation de votre tâche est de
celles des hommes et des femmes qui
travaillent avec vous donc voilà cette
mise au point je crois était utile et
c'est pourquoi je remercie allah richard
de nous y avoir conduit un homme
jourdain merci monsieur président
colonel nous sommes toujours dans la
recherche vous l'avez compris d'une
certaine vérité et la capacité de
comprendre quelles sont les
contradictions sur les propos des
différents propos qui sont tenus par les
uns et les autres notamment
il règne de fait alors à tort ou à
raison une certaine confusion sur le
rôle de de monsieur benalla dans ses
fonctions de protection pas du président
de la république et notamment lorsque
nous avons interrogé monsieur miss de
l'intérieur il nous a indiqué ne pas
connaître personnellement monsieur
benalla mail connaître bien évidemment
de vue et qu'il l'avait toujours pris
pour un policier
qu'est ce qui peut laisser croire dans
l'attitude de monsieur benalla puisque
j'espère le côtoie régulièrement qu'il
aurait un rôle de policier à quelqu'un
aussi aguerri que monsieur mise de
l'intérieur colonnes
la co rapporteurs vous comprendrez
aisément qu'il m'est difficile est
impossible de commenter les propos tenus
par monsieur le ministre l'intérieur
ceci étant dit pour moi en tant que chef
du j'espère pour mes personnels il n'y a
aucune confusion
monsieur benalla n'était pas officier de
sécurité
monsieur benalla je me permets de le
redire mais c'est important n'était ne
dirigeait pas de service sécurité ne
dirigeait pas le j'espère il était à la
chefferie cabinet changer de vision a
chargé de mission adjoint auprès du chef
de cabinet et à ce titre il avait un
rôle de facilitateur entre les
différents services j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure l'appellation de chef
d'orchestre au même type que tous les
autres membres de la chefferie cabinet
merci mon colonel
le tour est venu pour madame canayer de
poser sa question
oui merci monsieur le président colonel
ma question à peut-être à côté de la
plaque les jouer juste savoir concernant
l'émission de monsieur benalla vous nous
avez expliqué clairement le contenu de
ces missions avant et après le premier
vingt le treut la date de sa suspension
le 22 mai juin jusqu'au vote avant le 22
mai jusqu'au 22 mai moi je vous à
questions sur l'action qui s'est passé
dans l'eau au moment du retour des bleus
je savoir dans quel cadre rentrée la
participation de monsieur beynat large
c'est facile j'espère étaient mobilisés
sur cette manifestation
et avez vous eu vent avez vous au
courant de friction là aussi entre des
forces de l'ordre et monsieur benalla au
colonel
oui même la sénatrice le le président
république n'étant concernés sa
protection
ne relevant que du condor militaire
puisqu'il est au palais même pas ce que
je fais pas de compétences à leur
intérieur et extérieur
le président était pas n'étant pas en
déplacement pour le retour des bleus
bien évidemment le j'espère n'était pas
concerné par le retour des bleus ceci
étant dit la chefferie cabinet le
directeur de cabinet étaient concernés
par le retour des bleus et c'est à ce
titre là que monsieur benalla était
impliqué mais je pense que monsieur le
directeur de cabinet
les présences de république a répondu à
cette question là moi j'ai pas eu
connaissance de friction particulière
entre monsieur bénard et des membres des
forces de l'ordre
à cette occasion monsieur kerrouche
merci monsieur le président d'abord
parce que notre collègue anna richard a
pris la parole tout à l'heure il me
semble quand même que il a parlé de
prise de parole qu'il avait prise de
parole individuel de la part de monsieur
alexandre benalla au vu des éléments
dont nous disposons il semble par
ailleurs que monsieur benalla et était à
minima accompagné non non non il ne
semble pas dans l'article du monde
notamment il est fait très clairement
référence à certaines personnes qui
montrent que au delà de la stratégie
individuelle
on peut se poser la question de la
communication politique mais par
ailleurs ce n'est pas une je répondais à
votre je faisais un commentaire sur la
faire comme vous avez jugé utile de le
faire sur mon colonel juste une question
qui peut être périphériques mais qui
permettra peut-être de nous éclairer
enfin en tout cas en ce qui me concerne
sûrement je ne comprends pas il est
peut-être vous pourrez nous donner des
informations là-dessus le rôle et le
statut de monsieur vincent kraz au sein
de l'elysée
on parle de lui comme chargé de mission
est ce que vous pourriez nous donner des
exemples de de mobilisation de monsieur
de monsieur crasse par le commandement
militaire de la présidence de la
république pour nous éclairer sur ce
qu'il faisait exactement
est-ce que par ailleurs il y avait une
connaissance des liens qui existaient
entre monsieur kraz et monsieur
alexandre benaki par ailleurs semblait
bien se connaître où il y avait des
rencontres fortuites
on sait qu'ils avaient voulu créer une
société une société ensemble voilà et
donc il est peut-être pas indifférent
d'avoir des renseignements pour
comprendre pourquoi au final ils
finissent ensemble au même endroit le
1er mai mais c'est bien parti mais cette
dernière partie nous non pas
d'appréciation bien sûr de votre votre
part mon colonel
le sénateur concernant le rôle et le
statut de monsieur vincent kra zoo
s'analyser comme il le relevait il
communie ne relever que des
commanditaires
je ne peux pas m'exprimer au nom du
général biosphère et d'un conte en
militaire du palais puisqu'il était il
était sous l'autorité du général de
farine 1 en tant que réserviste et pas
sous l'autorité du chef du j'espère
concernant les liens entre monsieur
crasé monsieur benalla je savais qu'ils
se qui se connaissaient ni plus ni moins
bien
madame jean todt demande de parole merci
monsieur le président connell ce matin
nous avons entendu monsieur girier qui
sur interrogations nous a confirmé qu'un
agent de la sécurité de la campagne de
candidat emmanuel macron avait été
recrutée au sein du gspr alors nous
aurions souhaité savoir dans quelles
conditions s'est ainsi vu connaissiez
cette qualité d'anciens membres de la
sécurité de la campagne du candidat et
si le cas échéant
monsieur b n'a pu avoir un rôle
quelconque dans ce recrutement en
présentant ce candidat ou en appuyant sa
demande d'une quelconque façon ou de
tout autre moyen
mon colonel
lorsque le chef de cabinet du ministre
d'état ministre de l'intérieur et fait
référence et un agent de sécurité de qui
parle-t-il
il parle d'un agent dont il note qu'il
n'a pas nommés et qui est un ancien du
gign et qui tiendrait le rôle entre
guillemets de sièges vous êtes sur la
piste mon colonel
monsieur le président je remarque que
vous êtes bien renseigné riz se trouve
il se trouve que dans mon parcours
personnel et professionnel
j'ai été con en second du gign donc
effectivement je connais bien cette
personne
cette personne-là a été asservis 13 ans
au gign presque 14 a eu des mines en
état de service et a fait valoir ses
droits à la retraite a été dans la hâte
en gage et dans la sécurité privée
c'est son droit
effectivement lorsque il s'est agi de
constituer le j'espère il a été engagé
en tant que sous-officier commissionné
se résigner comme les traduire est
absolument absolument non mais je vais
pas vous laisser dans je donne des
précisions sur ce fils est commissionné
s'est soucié sous contrat donc il a été
entre guillemets réactivé en tant que
gendarme ayant dépassé la limite d'âge
pour servir au gign ils ne pouvaient pas
il ne pouvait plus être réaffectée au
gign et donc il était affecté à la garde
ce week-end la compagnie de sécurité de
la présence de république détaché au
gign pour servir au sein du groupe de
sécurité dès à présent un public mairie
pour répondre beaucoup plus clairement à
votre question
comme c'est quelqu'un vous imaginez que
je connaissais personnellement je n'ai
pas eu besoin d'avoir une orientation de
monsieur b d'alain pour faire en sorte
que cette personne là soit réactivée en
bonne et due forme pour pouvoir servir
entendre militaire la gendarmerie au
sein du j'espère où il n'y a que des
fonctionnaires de police du sdlp ou des
militaires gendarmerie merci de cette
réponse très claire en colonel madame
d'euromédis merci monsieur le président
colonel sur plusieurs photographies
monsieur benalla paraît porter des
assigne sur sa veste tels que ceux qui
sont portés par les membres du gspr jeu
trois questions est ce que c'est normal
s'agit-il des même un signe et enfin
d'autres membres de la chef de la
chefferie porte-t-il les mêmes un signe
mon colonel
il sait il ne s'agit pas des mêmes un
signe nous portant des insignes avec un
fond noir laqué j'espère les membres de
la chefferie cabinet et les conseillers
du président porte des pin's présidence
de la république qui sont dors et donc
qu'ils ont la même forme
c'est une forme circulaire mais qui ne
sont pas les mêmes ça permet
d'identifier très clairement et pour
palais qu'ils soient embêtés qu'ils
puissent continuer à travailler au plus
près du président et qu'ils soient
identifiés par les forces notamment des
forces de l'ordre lorsque l'offre
dépassant les présidents donc ces deux
pin vraiment différent la deuxième
catégorie de pinzi toupine c'est sûr des
pin's qui sont référencés par le chef de
cabinet ihs quand j sont délivrés
manière nominative et numérotée manière
à ce que il n'ya n'est pas tout le monde
en est pas bien évidemment merci de
votre réponse monsieur jacques bigot à
j'avais noté vous vouliez poser une
question ça n'est pas le cas madame sur
le groupe
merci monsieur le président colonel je
vous remercie parce que vous êtes très
précis dans les mots que vous employez
ce qui nous permet en effet de déclarer
probablement notre réflexion j'avais
noté précisément une phrase que vous
avez répété
vous nous avez bien dit vous n'avez
jamais vu monsieur benalla armées lors
des déplacements du président de la
république alors je vais me permettre de
revenir sur cette question je vous prie
de m'excuser et d'aller un tout petit
peu plus loin que la question de
monsieur pilet qui vous interrogeait sur
les permis de port d'armes
je voudrais savoir très précisément à
votre connaissance s'il serait possible
que monsieur benalla aient pu recevoir
une arme dite de dotation administrative
même si éventuellement il ne l'emmenez
pas avec lui lors des déplacements du
président de la république pour nous
c'est très important de comprendre au
delà de larmes parce que ça nous permet
de comprendre un petit peu mieux le
statut et la position de monsieur
benalla puisque vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que ces armes sont exclusivement
réservés aux fonctionnaires de police et
de gendarmerie
je remercie mon colonel c'est sûr très
précises sur le statut de larmes de
service
de monsieur ben alla et son origine sur
le statut de larmes détenus à titre
individuel par monsieur b n'a pas son
arme de service sont les armes de
service ont des armes pendant que les
personnels du j'espère ou en dotation je
me permets d'être précis sur la
terminologie parce que c'est pas anodin
rappelle que monsieur bénalia avait un
permis de port d'armes à raison des
fonctions de police qu à la présidence
de la république et donc mais c'est
intéressant de vous entendre apporter
une réponse précise à cette question
tout à fait monsieur le président
monsieur benalla avait me semble-t-il
j'ai vu récemment avait à titre
personnel déclaré un glock
quarante trois pour être précis
ce qui n'est absolument pas la dotation
des fonctionnaires du j'espère parce que
pour être plus précis les fonctions du
j'espère dispose de glock 17 de glock 19
de glock 26 et nous avons trois armes
d'instruction qui sont des glock 45 et
ce sont des dotations individuel donc
qui qui ne se prêtent pas donc les armes
sont complètement différentes
il n'y a pas d' amalgame ya pas de
dotation administratives pour monsieur
bénard a bien évidemment c'était donc
une arme personnelle qu'il avait acheté
avec ses deniers personnels
il me semble que c'est il me semble
merci monsieur le ministre il
il me semble que ça alors là que c'est
ce qu'il a indiqué dans la presse en
cette fois vous l'avez lu alors mon
colonel
gg ne j'ai une question complémentaires
puisqu'on parle de l'équipement de
monsieur benalla il était sa voiture la
voiture de fonction qu'il avait était
équipée d'un pare-brise police tous ne
sais pas ce que c'est qu'un pare brise
police à la place du miroir sur le pare
brise du passager avant
il y a réversible une mention police qui
est éclairée et qui permet aux agents de
police qui sont sur le chemin de la
voiture de laisser passer ce véhicule
pour lui permettre pour permettre aux
personnes qui sont à l'intérieur des
remplir leurs fonctions de police je
voudrais savoir si ces j'espère qu'ils
installent et 7 se pare brise
2 parce que le ministre de l'intérieur
nous dit nous a dit très clairement
qu'il n'avait rien à voir avec cela et
si ça n'est pas si ça n'est pas de
j'espère pour vous pourriez vous faire
une supposition sur l'origine de ce pare
brise oh oui oui oui alors vraiment il
faut tout corriger ces les pales par
brice est parti soleil évidemment et je
vous prie de m'excuser monsieur le
président ce n'est pas le j'espère
qu'ils équiper le véhicule de service de
monsieur b dallas et j'irai plus loin
qu'une supposition puisque c'est le
garage de l'elysée sous l'autorité du
général bio farina qui équipe les
différents véhicules de service des
collaborateurs et non en fonction des
collaborateurs du président au premier
rang desquelles les membres de la
chefferie cabinet notamment monsieur
benalla pour leur permettre
effectivement par rapport à leur
disponibilité de pouvoir être rapidement
sur les lieux où le président est ramené
à ce rang pour leur permettre également
de pouvoir intégrer un cortège en cas de
besoin donc là typiquement l'équipement
du véhicule qui ne concerne pas que le
pare soleil puisque vous avez ce qu'on
appelle aussi des feux de pénétration
bien est destiné à faciliter le service
nationaux collaborateurs et son
équipement standard des collaborateurs
qui ont des véhicules de service au sein
de présence merci de votre réponse
monsieur longuet oui merci monsieur le
président
d'abord je voudrais vous présenter mes
excuses mon clown elle je n'ai pas
entendu les débuts de votre intervention
et je vais vous poser une question un
peu général jeu
j'ai bien compris qu'il y avait un
gouverneur militaire qui défendent l
palais j'ai bien compris que le gspr
avait vocation à protéger le président
dans ses déplacements dans ses
déplacements publics
toute la question est de savoir qu'est
ce qu'un déplacement privé ou sari
timoko mon style et avec qui on parle et
vous l'avis d'un responsable politique
est contraignante celle du président de
la république est exceptionnellement
contraignante et on voudrait savoir
comment fonctionne entre le gspr chef de
cabinet commandement militaire la
protection de la vie puisque l'on
appelle la vie privée du président la
république si tenté qu'il puisse avoir
une vie privée qui le dit à quel moment
comment et qui s'en occupe pour éviter
pour respecter à la fois la personnalité
la liberté le président de la république
et en même temps ne crée aucune
condition qu'ils pourraient l'exposer
car à tout moment il reste le président
de la république française et à tout
moment il peut être exposée et il n'y a
pas de en quelque sorte de trêve de la
malveillance
il n'y a pas de trêve delà de la
violence éventuelle d'une agression
terroriste et donc comment gérez vous
cela
à l'intérieur du fonctionnement du
cabinet de la présidence globalement mon
colonel
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre je vais vous
apporter quelques précisions mais sans
rien dévoiler quelque part parce que
sans épuiser sans rien dévoiler surtout
parce que dans mes propos liminaire j'ai
indiqué que je ne pourrais pas rentrer
dans l'organisation interne de la
présidence qui l'an dernier dans les
différents modes d'action et les
déplacements officiels qu'on est pas son
nom officiel
nous avons des modes d'action qui sont
adaptés je dirais juste que vous êtes je
reprends votre terminologie où vous avez
indiqué que bon c'est pas un gouverneur
militaire c'est un conte d'hans milité
en fait c'est le corps militaire en fait
s'occupe de l'intérieur a la compétence
sur l'intérieur des emprises présentiel
le j'espère à la compétence de la
sécurité pas seulement sur les
dépassements public mais sur l'ensemble
des déplacements du président sur
l'ensemble des passants du président
c'est pour cette raison quand
j'expliquais tout à l'heure
exactement c'est quand physiquement y
met les pieds sur le trottoir lorsque le
président mitterrand allait acheter des
livres dont il était un collectionneur
est d'ailleurs un homme extrêmement
averti il l'était il aurait été sous le
contrôle du gspr je me permets de parler
de nom de mes anciens mais grands
anciens c'est pas il aurait été c'est
qu'il était et c'est la même chose
actuellement exactement pareil
absolument c'est la même chose
effectivement il y a le principe de base
est intangible c'est la permanence et la
continuité de la sécurité du chef de
l'état quel que soit l'endroit où ils se
trouvent et quel que soit l'heure du
jour ou de la nuit
allam jourda merci monsieur le président
je me permets de reformuler la question
en d'autres termes colonel cela signifie
t'il qu' à aucun moment le président la
république ne pas avoir le choix de son
mode de protection ni de l'intensité de
cette protection au colonel
[Musique]
je préciserai que vous comprendrez
madame la kora panther que là on rentre
dans des modalités d'action que j'ai
indiqué les propos liminaires et que je
ne pourrais pas répondre à ce type de
questions je dis simplement que les
différents modes d'action soient
adaptées aux circonstances
[Musique]
son poids son président un adapté aux
circonstances
voilà parce que c'est une question jeu
pour rebondir
l'adaptation va jusqu'au choix des
équipes et à la constitution des équipes
qui assure la sécurité du président mon
colonel
cela relève de mon autorité
donc de mon choix merci mon colonel
madame de la gontrie assez président
tout à l'heure a donc été évoquée a été
souligné la qualité des informations
qu'ils pouvaient être celles recueillies
par par la commission concernant donc le
l'intégration de cette personne qui n'a
pas de nom pour l'instant mais qui est
temps qu'un de vos anciens collègues
ancien du gign qui remplissait le rôle
de siège et donc dont vous avez indiqué
qu'il avait été intégrée au gspm
sachant que depuis le début de nos
auditions
nous nous entendons des des propos dont
je le dis avec alain richard ne le
disent nous ne connaissons pas là la
robustesse mais nous les entendons donc
on comprend que sept personnes avaient
participé à la campagne du candidat
macron et donc intègre ensuite le gspr
est ce que à votre connaissance
monsieur benalla jouer à jouer un rôle
puisque vous êtes le chef du j'espère
dans les recrutements de telle ou telle
personne sans
prendre enfin je ne vais pas jusqu'à
imaginer qu'il prenne la décision à
votre place si c'était le cas et bien
évidemment vous pourriez l'indiqué mais
est ce qu'il y avait un rôle de
recommandations de d'indication d'un
certain nombre de personnes puisque ça
semble avoir été le cas ou pas
concernant cet ancien du gign en colonel
vous avez déjà partiellement répondu à
la question mais au delà de mes cheveux
je vais je vais je vais je vais
reformuler encore ma réponse trévières
jeu j'ai précisé madame la sénatrice que
monsieur benalla ne met pas pousser à
recruter la personne auquel vous faites
référence est d'ailleurs je citerai pas
son nom parce que par souci de sécurité
bien évidemment c'est une personne que
je connaissais personnellement je
connaissais ses états de service je
travaille avec lui et très clairement
c'est c'était la demande c'est à la
demande particulière non pas de monsieur
mais n'a là mais d'une autre personne
que j'ai fait ça très clairement mais
j'en assume pleinement le choix tu as
fait et donc ça me permet de re préciser
que au delà de cette personne là
monsieur benalla n'a joué aucun rôle
dans le recrutement dans la composition
du j'espère je le redis monsieur rénale
à n'était pas office sécurité monsieur
benalla ne dirigeait pas le j'espère
monsieur benalla donc monsieur bédard
n'a pas joué de rôle dans le recrutement
des outils sécurité du j'espère
les les personnes qui ont joué un rôle
dans le recrutement des eaux sécurité du
j'espère à compter du gesppe air à
compter du 14 mai 2017 sont devant vous
il s'agit de commissaire divisionnaire
perroudon et de moi même parce que
monsieur perrault don à une connaissance
parfaite de la police nationale et du
service de la protection et moi je pense
avoir une bonne connaissance de la
maison gendarmerie donc ça nous a permis
effectivement d'avoir une approche très
fine le qui pouvait composer qui
devaient composer le j'espère qu'ils
devaient protéger le présent mâcon alors
nous en jeu vos crocs la réponse est
suffisante
à moins que vous vouliez préciser votre
question et avoir un complément madame
de la montrer très bien madame et
monsieur les rapporteurs avez-vous
d'ultimes question ce n'est pas le cas
chaque collègue vous non plus chers
collègues appuyé appuyer sur le bouton
de la bleue le glauque 43 c'est c'est un
calibre plus plus lourd
une arme d'arrêt c'est une clé l'un
parlez nous un peu du jeu 43 et est-ce
qu'on l'utilisé dans l'administration
française soit dans l'âge ingrat maurice
audin police en dehors du des services
de la norme au colonel une précision
technique sur cette arme sa portée et
son utilité alors traitement moi j'ai le
glock l'as rome 3 est une arme est une
arme une compacte comme tous les blocs
c'est une arme que l'on peut utiliser
qui est qui qu'on peut choisir par
rapport une bonne prise en main sa note
a normalement 9 mm comme comme l'écho
comme le bloc 17 comme le glock 19 comme
le bloc 26 ce n'est qu'à ce n'est qu'à 9
mm effectivement sa prise en main est
spécifique est là c'est assez fine par
rapport à par exemple bloc 17 bien mon
colonel s'il n'y a pas d'autres
questions
nous allons maintenant vous remercier de
votre coopération de la clarté de la
fermeté de vos réponses
cette audition est maintenant terminée
de même que la séance de la commission
demain nous nous retrouvons à 8 heures
pour entendre le délégué général du
mouvement la république en marche
monsieur castaner